you sort of have like implicit things
that if you work for a company and
if amy you know amy's my manager amy was
looking at this i know she would want it
done this way there's a certain
principle and maybe i can't even make it
explicit but like amy likes her excel
seats formatted in this way because it
you know it makes it easier to read or
or kind of whatever it is and so
you know i think maybe the system is
sort of like a level of abstraction like
a value
one for me would be something like
courage it's not like super clear
in most areas how you would apply how
would you be more courageous in your
relationships how would you be more
courageous at work and you there's
there's like lots of different ways
that could go whereas to me like
principles are a little bit less
abstract and like closer to where the
sort of rubber meets the road so like
you know i always have time for a good
friend
that's the sort of the more explicit we
call them like heuristics like a rule of
thumb
right like if this than that if this
happens then i do that it's kind of
operating principle whereas the value is
going to be more like courage or
uh integrity is a bad one i think
because like everyone should probably
have integrity but
but that sort of level of abstraction
before we get into today's podcast i
have to put a disclaimer out it is
absolutely sweltering in newcastle so
i'm wearing a vest
got loads of stick last time or a vest
but it's not a lack of care about this
podcast i'm super excited
to sit down with taylor pearson it's
just too warm you know i mean under a
bunch of lights
and uh it's challenging today but taylor
man welcome to the show
pleasure to be here glad you're staying
cool i'm trying well the problem is in
the uk it's only hot for like
five days of the year so no one has air
con but to not have aircon in a house in
america would be ridiculous right but
over here it's like why would you have
air con it's cold like
seven and a half months out of the urine
so here's what it is
uh so today we're going to talk about
core principles
and values i you've got a couple of blog
posts which
just blew me away when i read them at
the start of this year and have been a
huge influence
on me and i just wanted to give you the
opportunity to
tell the audience about why core values
and operating principles are so useful
why they're so important and then
kind of give us some insight into into
your thoughts on them
so to begin with do we all have core
values and operating principles because
you've got this big list
on your site 37 operating principles and
your
five core values and all this stuff if
someone hasn't written them out do they
still have them
guiding their actions yeah i think at
some level right you all have intrinsic
you know we all face decisions every day
you have like whatever mundane seasons
am i gonna have a salad for lunch or a
burger for lunch
you have you know who whatever who am i
going to marry who am i you know what am
i going to do
with the rest of my life blah blah blah
and you know you're there's there's some
algorithms to speak right you have some
internal way where you're like waiting
what's going on that decision and
choosing it one way or the other so
yeah to me it's it's something that um i
think everyone has
to some extent internally i i found
externalizing them you know sort of like
making them explicit where i can
uh kind of read them one can like help
me be a little bit more self-reflective
right like is this actually something
that i
think is important do i want to do this
and then you know oftentimes also just
i find out i'll sort of treat one area
of my life one way another area of my
life
in another way right and so i you know
when i sort of like put all those things
out on on paper if it forces me to be a
little bit more like oh like actually
this is like a bit hypocritical and
uh you know i could apply this to there
and that to there
so you use the learnings from certain
areas of your life
to progress your understanding in and
insights in different areas of your life
yeah i think you know to start maybe the
general operating principles the way
that kind of like originated for me
and i'm sure like everyone has this
experience is like you you do something
dumb
you make some mistake or you have some
like significant learning you're like
wow i really hope that in the future
like i don't do that thing
that way again like this is the correct
way to do that is actually this other
way
and like that's what i should do and uh
i guess i found myself like
just you know despite thinking that i
would then just like proceed to make the
same mistake
in some slightly different way uh at
some point in the future and so
um kind of the the way my general
operating principle started was like
okay
like you know this thing like i want to
remember this and so i'm going to write
it down
and i should put it in a place that i
can look over once a week or every other
week
uh typically around sort of like when i
once a week i'm planning out my week and
kind of what what am i going to
prioritize what does i'm going to make
and i'll read through that and you know
very frequently it's like oh like i'm
about to make that mistake
again uh you know for the 14th time kind
of thing but if you know if i if i have
it there and it's written and i can look
at it
i go ah like this you know um i can
notice that i'm doing this thing again
and i can be a little bit more uh
deliberate about it so having those
external eyes sort of written down has
been really helpful for me
you've touched there on the fact that
it's avoiding
mistakes rather than kind of expediting
successes
is this a um a focus on not being stupid
rather than trying to be clever
i think you can go either way i guess i
uh i probably spend more time trying not
to be stupid than
than trying to be clever um
you know yeah it's if you can uh
you know whether survival is the first
rule right you know if you if you can
officially not make up
any mistakes i think it's interesting um
you know i've read a lot of books i like
investing in businesses and
you know there's many many ways to get
rich and there's only a few ways to go
broke
and if you can just avoid all the ways
to go broke for long enough like you can
probably make it work out okay you know
like
there's a there's a lot of ways to do it
right but only a few ways to do it wrong
and so i guess that my
my bias i tend to focus on like if i can
just
not make any major mistakes here uh
i'll probably be okay don't multiply by
zero man no one wants to multiply by
zero
exactly yeah so why are core values and
operating principles
so useful is it just this sort of
compounding of wisdom across different
areas of your life is it just making
uh decisions less arduous
yeah i think it is um
i think it's just yeah for me at least
it's sort of like
being able to to be consistent and i
think part of it's you know i think you
feel
um it feels good when you're sort of you
know quote-unquote uh
in alignment you know there's a this uh
story i was like there's a
uh author uh michaeli ching
sent me high i'm sure i'm mispronouncing
his name um
but i've read a couple of his books and
he has this great story talking about uh
there was a study done in the 1990s
uh where they were looking at uh
geneticists and journalists they looked
at a bunch of different professions and
they're basically seeing like
who likes their job the most and why
like what makes someone like their job
and uh journalists were like the most
unhappy with their jobs
and geneticists were the happiest and
basically what they you know their
conclusion as to why that was was
um the way the incentives were
structured uh with the genesis is
everything
was aligned like the genesis really
believed that if they were just doing
the best science they possibly could
uh that was most likely about the you
know the drugs or the
pharmaceuticals whatever they were going
to help the most people and would make
the pharmaceutical company most money
right so everyone you know this if i can
just do the best science i possibly can
everyone else you know this is the best
thing for everyone and the 90s was kind
of when journalism had started to
a lot like big conglomerates she'd come
in and bought these media companies into
a lot of people that started journalism
careers because they were like
i want to report the truth and tell
important stories and all this kind of
stuff for writing
you know whatever the 1990s version of
buzzfeed kind of clickbait headlines
were
and that was what got the most uh told
most newspapers and surgeon or the most
advertising revenue but they were like
deeply unhappy
uh doing that as a job and so in the
same way like i think
you know i certainly go through periods
where like
i just kind of get off course you know i
just start like working on things or i
start doing things and it's like this
actually isn't like
i'm not really enjoying i'm not super
happy about this i'm not kind of
enjoying this and so
you know i don't think it was like uh
think about sort of like the way a plane
navigation system works
um you know it's always going slightly
off course right the plane is never
directly on the right you know if you're
flying from austin to london
uh or whatever you know you're always
gonna be slightly off course but it's
always just sort of error correction
right it's always
it's always just making it move back and
so like in practice it's close enough to
a straight line that it works well it's
like the same way here right i think the
the principles or the core values are
sort of that navigation system was just
like hey
like you know actually you you wanted to
go here and like if you want to change
your mind and go to
uh belarus or whatever like you can do
that but like let's be deliberate about
the decision
i love that i love the idea of being
deliberate as well recently had kyle
eschenroder on talking about working out
what you want to want
and so much of that is that the things
that people do are not done by design
you know it's the way that you dealt
with past traumas societal norms
genetic programming natural
predisposition whatever
all of these different things very
easily that can lead to you ending up in
a place
that you didn't want to be or even mean
to end up in
and looking back on looking back in a
life that you regret is like
that's what we all are trying to avoid
so hopefully today we can give
the listeners some tools that will help
them to not
lead a life that they regret so first up
what's the difference
between core values and operating
principles is there a difference
yeah so actually the contradiction is
from a business book
called work the system but it talks
about this like in the context of a
company so if you ever worked for a
company like
usually every company has their like
five or six core values and usually
they're like terrible and meaningless
it's like
integrity right it's like it's like
obviously you shouldn't lie to people
um uh but then you know every company i
think this is you know
the same with businesses or our
companies or individuals is
you sort of have like implicit things
that if you work for a company and
you know your manager your manager's
manager you know like oh if
if amy you know amy's my manager amy was
looking at this i know she would want it
done this way
right that's i know she has there's a
certain principle and maybe i can't even
make it explicit but like amy likes her
excel
sheets formatted in this way because it
you know it makes it easier to read or
you can make charts better or um
or kind of whatever it is and so you
know i think uh i guess it's maybe
like the easiest thing to sort of like a
level of abstraction like a value
like one for me would be something like
courage that's it's a fairly that's a
fairly abstract
concept right it's not like super clear
in most areas how you would apply and
how would you be more courageous in your
relationships or how would you be more
courageous at work and you there's like
lots of different ways
um that could go whereas to me like
principles are a little bit less
abstract and like closer to where the um
sort of rubber meets the road so like
you know i always have time for
for a good friend right like that that's
that's a much cleaner simpler
thing like if one of my best buddies
from high school calls me like
whatever's going on i can like make time
to like talk to him about
um whatever's going on so that's the
sort of
the more explicit um we call them like
heuristics like a rule of thumb
right like if this than that if this
happens then i do that it's kind of
operating principle whereas the value is
going to be more like yeah like a
courage or
integrity is a bad one i think because
like everyone should probably have
integrity but
but that sort of level of abstraction
yeah there's some
core values which shouldn't be
able they shouldn't be listed as a core
value they should just be
an accepted entry requirement for being
a human
not someone that says honesty is a core
value it's like well what's the [ __ ]
opposite
yeah it's like what like how's honesty
honesty isn't a core value honesty is
just the thing that you do it's like one
oh one of my core values happens to be
breathing
like no it's just it's how you literally
how you
continue within the world um i like the
idea of the
of the levels of abstraction i think
that's a good a good way to
to sort of split the two apart it's a
little bit like um
core values are the ingredients and
operating principles are the meals that
you can make from those ingredients
right you can make
multiple different meals from some of
the ingredients that you've got
but the ingredients do actually
influence you know if you've
not got any dough you can't make a pizza
you might not be a pizza guy but if
you've got tons of whatever it might be
you can make a different sort of a meal
um sure can you tell us what your core
values are that'll be quite cool
yeah now i have them written down
because i actually forget them which i
think is case in point about writing
them down but um
you know uh i think one for me is like
agency
and that's just kind of like um uh it's
important to me it's a provider that i
have a lot of control over sort of how i
live my life you know like
i guess a lot of the ways these things
sort of developed to me is just
noticing things that like bothered me or
just just ways in which you behave
differently and so
i just felt like most most people could
like put up with like a bad job or
someone they didn't like
i just couldn't put up with it you know
i would just like 15 minutes in a
conversation with someone i didn't like
like i just couldn't
suck it up and deal with it and talk to
them for the next hour at the conference
or whatever like i just had to get out
of there
um you know whatever would just do the
irish goodbye and like walk out of the
conversation and
uh and go for it um so agency sort of
choosing how i live and
and helping others you likewise um you
know like self-development in some
capacity and like kind of like learning
has always been like very important to
me like i if i don't read for long
enough i get like very cranky my wife
will tell me to like go away and like
take some time
just like do a little bit of reading
leave leave the kitchen
go and grab a book you're on the naughty
step with your book for 15 minutes until
you come back yeah that's right but and
then i'm in a much better outcome back
and i'm just like oh it was so
interesting i really enjoyed that thanks
um yeah courage was one i mentioned
that's another one that
um that has come up for me a lot and i
think applies in sort of there's a lot
of different areas of my life where i
found that i was
basically unhappy because i felt like i
was lacking kind of courage
in retrospect um i think sorry
am i right in saying that courage was
one of the ones that you put
where you didn't feel like it was
something you necessarily did naturally
but was a guiding value which helped you
to operate
more effectively when you had it is that
that one
yeah i don't know how typical that is to
me or or in general but you know as like
you face some challenging decision
you're like maybe i'd rather not make
this decision or i'd rather sort of make
the
easier path but you know at some point
it became clear like if i reflected on
past decisions like you know typically
the more courageous
choice i was happy with in retrospect
that's really interesting so i remember
reading the blog post the first time i
read it
around about christmas time and thinking
that was a really clever way
to identify one of your values because
what's quite easy to do here
is to um reverse engineer
this is the sort of person that i am
therefore these are the five
values which are most close to the
person that i am
it's like i am a person that is you know
if your list of 67 was a list of 5 000
and it had all the bad stuff in there as
well it's like
i'm a person who is shy and timid and
uh easily irritated and blah blah blah
you know quick to judgment and all this
sort of stuff
um what you've done is you've set a
north star
for something that you want to be not
necessarily
a an existing disposition that you have
you know like that's the the agency
thing is something that
is inherent and inbuilt into you whereas
the courage thing is something that you
are looking to try and put more of
into your life right yeah and i think
you know i guess those two just as we're
talking
i'm thinking about it um you know
something that's been sort of
uh very influential army there's a guy
named joseph campbell you know i've
talked to him before he's a he was a
professor i think in like the 70s and
80s
uh but he wrote a book called um hero
with a thousand faces
and then he kind of became well known to
vixen he was well known he was kind of
the influence
on george lucas of the writing of star
wars that he had studied all these sort
of like ancient myths
uh religious stories like you know bible
northwestern uh native american
et cetera and this idea of the hero with
a thousand faces is
all these these myths across all these
different cultures are actually telling
a very similar story there's a certain
structure underlying the story
um and the reason that's evolved in all
these different cultures is because it's
it's a way of sort of teaching people uh
how to deal with the various things in
their life right you can read these
stories you read a good like fiction
book or
um kind of thing and you can say you can
see how it could apply to your life oh
like i'm not dealing with this exact
problem but
um something like that and one of the
keys so he broke it down into
um 12 stages of this the hero's journey
that you know the hero
confronts a problem they set off on a
challenge they overcome difficulties
and they come back and then they bring
their knowledge to the world and they're
sort of like teaching right you could
like see this in star wars you can see
this in the bible like this is very sort
of like
um universal uh mythology but
at the moment sort of i think it's like
the third stage in the way he describes
it
is what he calls the refusal of the call
that you have something that's calling
you
uh you know okay like uh if you're like
luke and star wars right it's like uh
he's being called by obi-wan to like go
on this quest and do this thing he's
like no i have to stay
i'm a willing hero yeah take care of my
parents and i can't go off with you and
then eventually you have the crossing of
the threshold right where the hero
accepts the call to adventure and they
step into this new world
of you know and decided in star wars
it's like if you remember the scene
where luke goes to um
this like weird bar there's like all
these aliens there and it's like crazy
and he's like never seen all these
different
um sort of things but you can think
about that as sort of like a
metaphorical
things anyway going about this idea of
like uh agency and courage right it's
that you know
i i realized in retrospect those those
times when i sort of approached the
threshold
you know there were times i had turned
away and there were times i had chosen
to cross
the threshold i had some courage seem to
step into this unknown world
um and do something you know whatever
sometimes the unknown world is uh
something that
that's seemingly quite small like you
know going to a different school
whatever it's going to be um but in all
those cases that was meaningful and so
you know i sort of could reflect on
those past experiences and say actually
this thing when i when i sort of
have courage in this capacity when i
accept this
uh this call to adventure uh that ends
up working out very well for me you know
in retrospect right i can look at major
life turning points and they all sort of
had that
that archetype in common yeah so that's
a
pre-disposition before making a good
choice tends to be something which comes
just before a prelude to that so okay
we got the first three what else have
you got um
so soul in the game is another one uh
for me and this i guess this one is a
bit new i got this from um
there's a guy named naseem tuleb who's
written a few books probably the most
famous is a book called the black swan
he was a
financial traitor uh but he talks about
this idea of you know there's
skin in the game which is kind of like
hammurabi's code right it's like it's an
eye for an eye it's like if you're going
to
you know the way in like ancient
babylonia there are certain rules like
if you
uh if you built a house and the house
collapsed and killed the people inside
you would also be killed right so you
were very incentivized to make sure the
house
was a good house right or you know if
you're if you're the architect building
the bridge you have to live under the
bridge right you want to make sure
that the bridge does you know what you
say the bridge
um money is going to do yeah and it's
it's the idea is there should be a
symmetry and risk
right like you shouldn't be allowing
others to take risk
uh for you right you should have the
same experience if i'm yeah i'm building
houses like it's not fair that i'm gonna
live in a house built by someone else
that's better at than me
and i'm gonna put everyone else in my
crappy house that i don't know what i'm
doing and you know they're gonna be at
risk or whatever
and so soul in the game is kind of an
extension of that concept it's when uh
it's when you take on risk for others
right you mean i think you know you do
this with a friend or people in your
family whatever it is it's they you know
they have something going on
and you bear some of that uh that burden
or that um
that risk for them so that's that's kind
of the idea of
um of soul in the game and again that
was sort of a i got that from his book
and i really liked it and i sort of
again kind of reflect on i was like you
know when i when i sort of do this
when i'm um when i have skin in the game
when i have soul in the game
and have that risk there i just feel
better you know i can uh
i just feel better about it right like i
just feel confident what i'm doing
that's cool and what's last is it five
you've got uh five yet and the last one
is just reciprocity
um they create more value than i capture
you know there's a
i got that from and you know you see a
lot of these i basically barred from
other people and they resonated for some
reason or another and
um and i put them down but um that
tim o'reilly from o'reilly media is a
big they do sort of like tech publishing
books
and they had some funny moment i think
they had published a book on like
uh c plus plus programming language and
they got an email from this guy that was
like
i just sold a five billion dollar
company based on
your like fifty dollar book on c plus
plus that i read and then built this
software and did uh so they were joking
they were like well at least we create
more create more value than we capture
right like you know we spawned this
500 companies made fifty dollars and
that's an extreme example but
it's like yeah like that that that to me
seemed like an important principle right
like i want i want there to be sort of
more value
created than i'm just capturing myself
you want it to be a sort of net positive
that's beautiful man they i mean you
know if you've got those things
as the foundation to your life
that sits below the building you build
on top of it or is the ingredients that
are going in you know if those are the
ingredients
i challenge you to make a [ __ ] meal out
of that i think it's gonna be
challenging to have a [ __ ] meal as long
as you stick to those good ingredients
and you build out of those
um so mine i did mine um
when i followed the exercise that you
have on your blog and
everyone that's listening it will be
linked in the show notes below i really
really highly suggest that once you've
finished listening to this podcast
you go and do the five the core values
exercise
take you said 15 minutes which
it might take someone 15 minutes but it
took me a couple of days
because getting it down to five it
wasn't hard
finding them it was reducing it down to
five oh
i can't get rid of that one i can't like
i can't get rid of that one that's the
that's the that's that one so but anyway
i managed to get it down and mine
spelled out an acronym which actually
helped me
to bypass the forgetting them oh that
that's smart
yeah i know um so it spells out cases
c-a-s-e-s so curiosity uh to be curious
to explore myself and the world around
me to meet new people
uh a adventure to um see new places do
new things
i want to live life to the fullest uh s
was actually
a steal from you about the soul in the
game which was where you'd taken a
concept and then
reworked it and it was selfless
development so it was to improve myself
learn how to operate effectively and
then teach others what i have learned
uh e excellence um to make the most of
minutes i want to be precise with my
thoughts words and actions
i want to fulfill my potential uh and
then the final s was self-care
in order to be everything that i need to
be for everyone else i need to look
after myself first and foremost
um and having those having that those
five principles man at the start of the
year
has made a really profound impact
because every time that i'm
faced with one of the thousand
inquisition size questions that we ask
ourselves about
do i go for a walk do i go to bed on
time do i get up on time do i hit the
snooze button do i
look at my phone while i'm in the car do
i do whatever it might be like all of
these different things i'm like well
okay how does it
how does it apply to these and having
the
balance and i think this is why the
cutting the chopping um
task was so difficult because
you understand that the balancing act is
quite important as well if you're gonna
have a maximum of five
so for instance for me excellence
actually is really really applicable
to a lot of the different things but
curiosity kind of guides the direction
so excellence can kind of be how
curiosity and adventure are in motion
and finding that balance but yeah
everyone that's listening you need to go
and do
the values exercise if you can do it in
the space of an hour i'll be really
really impressed
maybe you just happen to look upon it
but you give it's like a big chunk of
like 70
potentials and then other people can add
their own in um
but dude i i think it's a really lovely
way to
kind of just reset the way that you
operate within the world right ensure
that you are
aligned as you said that your thoughts
words and actions are aligned with
actually who you want to be who you are
yeah it's interesting i know i'm curious
like i know i found
i sort of sat down and did these once
and i remember particularly like the
soul and the game one i kind of remember
kind of coming to that and like actually
like i see this is really important to
me
and i find when i when i was sort of
write these down that as i said like i
would
i would sometimes be applying them to
one part of my life but not others and i
just remember sort of like i would have
to
i would reprocess everything right like
oh like i'm doing this over here in this
relationship and i'm doing this over
here at work and i'm doing this and this
other work project
and like it it's congruent here but it's
not congruent you know
in one of these uh two places and so
like having an external arm every time i
sort of like write one of these down
i'd like oh i gotta like think through
everything again a little bit you know
just sort of like reprocess
like oh like the reason i'm unhappy
about this is actually because
you know i'm i'm avoiding you know some
difficult conversation instead of being
courageous about or whatever it is
that third party perspective makes a big
difference
right treating yourself as if you're
someone you're responsible for helping
yeah i think it is a useful kind of
construct right because you can sort of
separate
um yourself the thinker from yourself
the
the actor to some extent yeah that one
and two
um love it's man it's just uh
it's so it's so interesting to me to see
how this rolls forward in people's lives
because everyone that's listening knows
what their mums or their sisters or
their partners
core values are sometimes they're
actually living really really bad core
values
like um i constantly concern myself with
what other people think of me
like so that would be like a a hyper
awareness or a hyper kind of
self-consciousness or whatever it might
be
and if you you by writing them out and
having them there it's almost like a
um a checklist right that you've got to
go through it's like
are you doing this are you being
courageous are you having soul in the
game etc etc
um so moving on to the operating
principles
of which you've got 37 and these are so
cool
and i absolutely love the idea of
creating this kind of compounding
library
uh like iterating on lessons and
things principles that you can do so
could you
talk about sort of where you started
with this
can you remember that story as well from
was it we were in vietnam or thailand or
something like that
uh yeah i want i was a friend of mine it
was actually my roommate at the time
i think and again like one of these sort
of uh daily decisions it was like i
think friday afternoon like 3 p.m
and he was like going to the beach and
he was like do you want to go to the
beach and this was like agonizing
because i was like well yeah i kind of
want to go to the beach and like hang
out and like
chill out and have a drink and whatever
like but i also like have this like work
project that i like said i was gonna do
on saturday and like i haven't worked
out this week so i should like probably
stay and
work out tomorrow and um so just you
know a second
from three to four p.m on friday i'm
sure there's and it's you know to some
extent
it's like it doesn't matter that much
right like this individual decision
uh doesn't matter but um you know i
compounded it does matter right like if
you if you miss one workout like it
doesn't really matter if you miss every
workout
uh it matters a lot um
and so i started uh i was like okay i
need to like have some
way to like make these decisions better
right like it's i mean i'm spending like
an ordinary amount of time
you know deliberating on these uh these
sorts of things and
you know again like it's this this one
in particular doesn't matter right like
an uh
i think i i did i ended up not going to
the beach but had i gone to the beach
like it's not the trajectory of my life
would not have been meaningfully
different had all
sort of other things stayed the same um
and so i sat down that weekend i think i
wrote through like the first version and
at the time was maybe like six
to ten um sort of operating principles
and they were just sort of like things
that at that point in my life
uh i had in my head right you know and i
think one of them was sort of this idea
of kind of like an integrated
uh life like my bias is i tend to just
get really sucked into
uh usually my work and like what i'm
doing professionally and like i
mean it happens to me all the time uh
two months ago i like i track
sort of my um how many work hours and i
was like doing 80 to 90 hour weeks
i was just like at the computer all the
time and i was like i can't you know i
can't do this right like this is not
um this is not sustainable um and then
what i would do is i
i just put that i have them in an excel
spreadsheet and i'll look at them
uh usually like every saturday morning i
sort of plan my weeks out you sort of
do a weekly review and weekly planning
first thing saturday morning
and um i would just notice you know i
would again like
these certain mistakes right i would
just do the same dumb thing
over and over and over and i'd be like
oh i should like stop doing
i stopped doing that dumb thing or you
know the inverse it's like i like when i
do this thing like i'm really
happy about it and it like works out
really well for me i should just like do
that thing
um kind of more consistently so you know
periodically
weeks when those things came out to me i
would sort of add them to the list
of like here's sort of another kind of
operating principle that i find
you know i can look at multiple
instances in my life where we're
following this was beneficial
yeah uh you know the other i sure talked
about this idea of the hero's journey
and the
the crossing the threshold there's a
book called the war of art that i really
like
about a guy named steve pressfield he's
uh he wrote uh the legend about a
tiger van became a movie about the
golfer
he has a couple other famous books about
um like i think sparr
[Music]
sort of spartan war or whatever but he
wrote this book about his sort of
journey to becoming a writer
and he talked about this idea of the
resistance right that we all have this
voice in the back of our head whenever
you're setting out to do something no
new that says you know you can't do it
right whether you're going to start
exercising or doing yoga or start a
business or write a book or
uh have a relationship whatever it is
you're just like no you can't
do this like this is gonna suck and so
he talked about sort of his own journey
as a writer of like
uh having this resistance in the back of
his head that he was basically bumming
around and like waiting tables and
doing a bunch of odd jobs for a decade
and he was like this was just the
resistance kind of kicking my ass right
like i just
was getting beat down by this thing and
so part of this thing is you know
we all need to sort of uh fight by the
resistance you know you go to war with
the resistance you have to see where in
your life is kind of that resistance
where is the resistance
and um you know how can you how can you
sort of like lean into that right lean
into whatever that thing is that you can
uh feel yourself avoiding and so that
that you know that was a great thing
because i
having read that book the sense for what
he meant by the
resistance
but if you if you read the book you get
the sense for like i can feel that right
and um
that's a question like i ask myself
every week you know where where am i
avoiding the resistance right where are
the areas that i'm avoiding the
resistance
and i mean it comes up very frequently
you know i'm avoiding a difficult
conversation with a business partner
or you know i'm avoiding um letting go
of a client because of what you know
whatever it is
um so that one um
that's awesome like especially because
our
evolutionary predisposition is to avoid
change right
like it we we try actively we don't want
to do the new thing because
the new thing might have a tiger in it
or the new thing might have a snake
hiding under it or whatever it might be
plus it's expensive you know energy wise
and cognitively and
i always use this same example but um
i posted about your um
uder loop blog post oh yeah a while ago
dude i've nearly finished uh i've nearly
finished the book on john boyd as well
the um one of the biology rubber quorum
yeah not great
massive though it's so long i just keeps
on going
um anyway this particular way of doing
decision making and and kind of um
reflecting on on on the way that you
operate within the world
and i can like pull some stuff up about
that which is a game changer right i
really love it i love the idea
of that post that up no one cares every
time that i post up
me using alpha brain by on it which is
a nootropic my inbox gets x-bob
dude is this any i'm like that's the
resistance there
the resistance is the the trick is the
five minute booty blaster ab
at home dvd for six pack abs in
20 seconds that's what that's what
because
uh hey man i'm really struggling with my
motivation on my procrastination to get
this thing done for university
okay um what's what's the best
productivity should i use rescue time
or should i actually be doing freedom
tied in with pomodoros and blah blah
and i'm like do you have your phone out
at your desk
yes right
is that you know like it's staring you
in the face yeah but again it's that
it's the resistance right and it's often
the things that we don't want to do and
then
when you layer on top of that a lot of
what we do is just signaling both to
ourselves in terms of self-deception and
to other people to make them think that
we're doing a thing and that we're
actually in control
it is increasingly as i read more and
more evolutionary psychology
i realize that externalizing the the way
that we operate
is almost mandatory because like if you
make a decision based on just like what
you think at the time it's almost
definitely going to be wrong like the
fact that we don't get hit by open
traffic
on a daily basis is a bit of a miracle
you know like why we just there's just
your decision making is awful at the
time yeah
it's terrible um i'd say one of the ones
that i absolutely adore which i've
started using
number 20 i go into terminator mode at
85 percent complete
once i get to 85 complete i start
obsessively focusing on the project
that's 85
complete the mind will play all sorts of
tricks on me
if i let it trying to seduce me into
doing something
unrelated on you i never give in to that
i get hungry and focused when i get to
85 percent complete
i get it done sebastian marshall
yeah i i mentioned i got that from um
from my friend sebastian but i like that
you know and i was kind of placing the
resistance but i don't know i feel like
everyone deals with this you get
when you start thinking about you get
the best stage of the project what
you're talking about other people
judging it right like other people
thinking about it
your head just starts to play all these
little tricks on your it's like well
maybe this isn't the appropriate thing
for you to do
at this point with where the brand is
going and you know maybe just put this
on the shelf a little while and like do
the
um the other thing or even you know i
notice i write like a weekly newsletter
and maybe
from the time i start writing time i'm
done maybe it's two hours you know it's
not that long
but at like 90 minutes i'm like nah
i don't know if this one's good like
maybe i'll just skip this issue this one
kind of sucks
uh and i'll just like wait in uh and do
the next issue and it's
i mean it did like i don't know how many
i published
300 something articles on the internet
it's like every article basically was
the exact same thing right like maybe
there was like
two you know yeah like
maybe two episodes like oh that was
really good but like most of them i'm
like no this probably sucks like i don't
know like i just kind of like go for it
uh kind of thinking so that again like
that was a mistake i saw myself making
over and over and i was like okay and
then you know i was talking sebastian's
like that's a great rule right like if
it gets to 85 percent if you get that
close to getting it done
like you just you just do it right and
the other way i've heard it phrased is
you know take
take the take the roast out of the oven
or take the turkey out of an oven you
know if you cook a turkey
eighty percent of the way it's totally
useless right
you can't you can't eat at 80 of the way
cooked turkey right it might as well be
raw like
just finish cooking the turkey and like
even if it's not the best turkey
like that's okay like you can just use
it to make soup or something you know
you've got something you can
you can start with that's awesome man
what else you got what else are some of
your favorites from your operating
principles that stand out
um yeah i think another one that i come
back to a lot is this idea of um
uh kind of like power laws or sort of
how you
you frame decisions i think like the we
tend to think of you know you talk to
about like resistance to change but like
we tend to think of things in like uh
as like relatively incremental right
like i'm doing something this way maybe
i could make it like
um five or ten percent uh better and the
idea of a power law parallel is like a
10x improvement right and so it's if as
this forcing function's like how what
would it look like if this was like
10 times better um or you know ten times
more
whatever the thing you want it to be is
um
and as a it forces you to think about it
differently
right you know if you're you're running
a business and you get
uh your customers because you go to
meetups in your local city or whatever
you can't go to ten times as many
meetups right like it just won't
there's there's no way just doing more
you can't just do ten times more of what
you're doing
there's not enough time so you have to
think about you know
it forces you to reference like well
okay like you know should i
do i hire people to go to meetups do i
also do this other thing but it forces i
think this sort of uh
deforesting function of um you know how
to think about
things uh differently i find that's
often you know my
my bias is to just kind of like grind
away right like i'll just keep running
away at this and like maybe it'll get
five
percent better this year and whatever
and you know there's we said for that at
some point but you know you also need to
have this thing of like you know what
would it look like to to sort of make
this thing 10 times better in
in some capacity and usually that means
kind of reinventing the thing from the
ground up
yeah it's challenging that though we
often i often talk about this at work
that
the boys i run a nightclub events
company
have done for 14 years and a lot of the
boys will come in and
continue to grind away with the same
strategy that got them a [ __ ] score for
their team last week
and the week before and the week before
and the week before and the week before
and i'm like man
like if anything what you've done is
proven to yourself that this particular
strategy
is ineffective achieving the goal that
you want
like this is an identifier this is you
constantly stepping on a mine
then getting an artificial limb refitted
next
each week and then going well is that
mine i know i know the last
like five times i've done it that's
happened but this time
might be different and it is is that
just that there's a there's a cost
there's a challenge with that
orthogonal lateral thinking do you think
that's that's a big part of it
do we like to routine eyes stuff
therefore we continue to grease the
groove we're already in
yeah i don't know why i mean i wonder
part of it's like uh
as you said just there are some just
like resistance to ch like you know
the way you're doing it's not working
but it's not working in a fairly
predictable
uh way right no this isn't working
this is gonna fail but it's not gonna
fail in some spectacular
embarrassing terrible way it's just
gonna fail in a very normal
predictable way and like i think and i
guess that's true right like a lot of
times it's like i would rather
people would rather fail in some you
know they'd rather have it go badly in
some predictable way than like take some
risks like well if i try doing it this
weird different way it could it could
spectacularly go wrong right like this
could end really badly
this is this is why i think people have
a
um aversion to
driverless cars or self-driving cars i
think people would much sooner be killed
at the mo at the behest of a human and
survive at the mercy of a robot
like they just think like there's a lot
more look at
every single stat that you've got every
single statistic about how many road
deaths are especially in america it's
crazy
total number of road deaths that occurs
like it's a real big number
you think if we had all of the
appropriate technology moving forward we
think we could reduce road deaths by
and it's some stupid margin that's like
80 90 something like that yeah um
but there's an aversion to it it's like
why well
like you know the deaths that we do have
like the mistakes that i do make at
least i know that it's like
mine to bear i don't know but i think
that's i think that's a lot of it it's
that sort of
existing paradigms right people don't
like new yeah i get visually i
there's like the evolutionary psychology
they take theirs and you know it's like
if you go if i go forage over here
it kind of sucks and i just barely get
enough food to live but like there's no
lions hiding in the bushes
over there right whereas like if i go to
this other place it could be way better
but like there could be a lion in the
bush or there could be like poisonous
snakes or like whatever it is so like
maybe
uh and again i think there's i think
that's it's hard to parse out because
like there is some wisdom
in that right like if it is going to
fail don't multiply by zero we said
truly
right if there's a there's a lion hiding
in the bushes like
you shouldn't go there right like it
doesn't matter how delicious the berries
are on the other side of the lion like
it's not worth it you know don't go
through the life
you don't go through the line but i
think that's there is
you know particularly for myself i think
this is generally true like
uh you know you you get hung up on other
people's perception of of whatever it is
right like
the quote-unquote lion is something more
like
you know my friends are going to think
i'm dumb or the people at this
then you're going to think i'm dumb uh
or whatever it is and like that's
that's scary again like i think the
evolution of college the explanation
here
makes some sense right it's like if you
get thrown out of the tribe and you're
left on the savannah all by yourself
like
you're screwed right so like you gotta
even even if you're not it's not the
best thing like you gotta make sure that
the tribe kind of likes you and i think
one of the
one of the nice things about the present
day and you know the internet is like
you kind of get to pick your tribe right
[ __ ] the tribe you kind of get to figure
out
who you want to hang out with yeah um
how should people so
the core values we've got that in an
exercise that people can go and do on
your blog
but the operating principles are a
little bit more iterative right it's
kind of a
compounding library that you acquire
yourself as you see things so how would
you advise someone someone says
[ __ ] l like that taylor guy told me i
need some core values and operating
principles and i haven't got any like
how do i start
compiling my operating principles what
should they do
yeah i think uh i mean you can link to
the article but like
read mine in other people's and like
maybe you get some ideas and i like as
a lot of mine as you you know recorded
the terminator one from sebastian like
that actually wasn't my idea right like
he just said that and i was like oh yeah
actually like if i did that
things would work out better for me and
i should kind of just start doing that
um so i think yeah you can use it from
other people and then i think
uh having just some sort of reminder i
don't know once a
once a week once a month where you sit
down and you you
read over whatever you have and you
think about like is there something else
that i would
uh add to this lesson that's my i think
mine uh
i sort of have my internal version
that's maybe like 45 or 50 now but i
don't know maybe every year i find like
three to five
right like it just kind of slowly
incrementally uh
grows as you know new things come up for
me that's awesome i'm
to give you a couple of mine so i've
only been working on i haven't taken any
of yours although a lot of yours are
phenomenal um but i've been building
mine up in preparation as soon as we
put this podcast in so one of them is uh
from ethan supply
guy that was in the butterfly effect and
my name is earl he was on the podcast
two weeks ago
and um he's got this thing from a coach
that taught in martial arts called no
bad reps
and basically it's that you're always
drilling something
in a very very real way from a
neurological perspective
everything is a habit whether you choose
to continue to do an existing good habit
break the good habit do a bad habit
break the bad habit
everything you do is building an action
which is more likely to occur in future
and there's this um the partitioned
brain approach which is in uh why
buddhism is true
by robert wright and he talks about the
modular brain sorry
um and he talks about that as well that
it's like which module wins
does the i eat a cookie module win or
does the i don't does the
i trade uh decide to go to the gym or
not and um
ethan's coach for martial arts is saying
like you're going to do this movement
you can either drill it and make the
next time that you do it compound on
something that's better or you can do it
with poor technique
and next time you've got to undo that
plus then try and get yourself better
again
so no bad reps and i thought
that was just like a a sick operating
principle and it was like quite cool
that it was just sort of three words
um and then another one from naval
and this is linked with thiago forte who
his most successful tweet of all time
uh naval's is escape competition with
authenticity no one can beat you up
being you
um and then thiago has you can't compete
with someone who's having fun
but escape competition with authenticity
no one can beat you at being you
is just it ties in so much
of the stuff that i i've learned from
doing this podcast and speaking to cool
interesting people like you
and um the fact that your competitive
advantage
is your unique mix of background
and talents and the the funny way that
you pronounce the letter t
and you know all the stuff the fact that
you
wake up and your back hurts everything
that you have
coalesces to become your unique offering
to the world and that is your
competitive advantage
because it's your ability for
authenticity so those are those are my
the two that i've got for now the no bad
reps and the escape competition with
authenticity
i like that it is useful to sort of
borrow them from either like the no bad
raps right like obviously that's
applying to like martial arts or
exercise or whatever but you can it's
fairly easy to sort of like generalize
that to
uh other things right you know whatever
you're you're working on a podcast or an
article like you don't sort of
everything is like some level of focus
right like i'm not going to just like
mail it in on this one
yeah no i agree um so one of the things
i wanted to touch on
before we finished was you get this
really interesting article about the
truth about working smarter
not harder can you take us through that
the i think you you say that there's
five there's only three ways to work
smart not harder but then when you read
the article there's five
uh well there you go that's uh truth in
advertising
that's fine well that's that's how you
sign up and you think you were just
getting three
but it's bonus yeah it's actually his d
he's the dvd extras so
um prioritize tasks by energy level
what's that mean
um yeah so i think like one way
you think about like sort of how many
i'm gonna have this much time this much
work and we tend to tend to chunk it up
into time um
i think it's it's probably more useful
to think about in terms of energy so i
got for me
like 9 00 am to 12 p.m in the morning
like my productive output
at that time relative to say 9 p.m to 12
a.m
at night is like a factor of 10 like
it's vastly better like i've never
in my life create anything useful after
10 pm at night right like it's just
nothing
nothing nothing good happens there like
basically everything has been you know
between nine
and um and 12 kind of thing and so i
most people don't you just wake up in
the morning and you're just like i just
start kind of doing the things i gotta
do right and like you know for example
like
for me it's like if i start and i just
like do a bunch of administrative stuff
at the first thing in the morning now
like my best energy when i like my head
was clear and everything was straight i
just spent like
sorting out my bookkeeping or you know
whatever you know
trying to set an appointment with
someone that you know isn't
coordinating well or whatever it is uh
and it's just like it's a bad use of
that time and so like
that kind of thing it's like i'll do
that at like five o'clock in the
afternoon because like i'm tired
you know it's i've already done a bunch
of stuff today i can like call the fedex
guy
and like coordinate the delivery uh and
like that's fine it's not
sort of energy so i'm thinking about
like what are the things you want to do
you know writing for me is a big one
that's like a high energy thing right so
i try to
i'm looking at sort of how i'm
organizing my time right like i want to
have that in big blocks in the morning
and then i want to sort of organize
everything else um
around that kind of stuff cool okay i i
really like that idea man i think
it's one of the it's a unifying no
matter whether you're coming in from gtd
or whether you're an ooda loop guy or
whether you're the optimizing for
optionality dude or whatever it might be
like no matter what your approach is
prioritizing uh matching the task with
the energy level
is definitely right and you you know
someone else might be i've never created
anything useful in my life before 3 p.m
everybody alex o'connor sure alex
o'connor that runs the cosmic skeptic
uh youtube channel and um his
his university like
sleep and wake cycle makes me feel
physically ill
like he he starts writing his oxford
university theology and philosophy
essays at 10 11 p.m
it's like he he starts winding up for
work at that time
and then he'll go to bed at like 5 00
a.m or 6 a.m
but he'll go into his halls of residence
or whatever in oxford
and um go to his uh
whole mates down the down the hall at
2am and play piano as a break for 30
minutes
like his whole mate will also be up at
that time and they'll do a bit of piano
and i'm thinking
[ __ ] 2 30 in the morning go to bed
a good bet but that for him that's the
cadence that works right so he's
matching his energy
with the tasks that he's doing even
apparently playing the piano
so your second second one is learn new
skills
how can that help us work smart and
harder
yeah i think i mean this one is maybe
the the simplest or the
the most obvious but um like being
deliberate about like
i like this idea of like uh of no bad
raps i
i was thinking about this my my first
job was in marketing not sort of my
original professional background
and i would meet these people that had
you know quote unquote five years of
marketing experience
and would just do like really you know
just something that not someone would
you wouldn't know like off the street or
whatever but like if you'd been working
in a career for five years like you
should have learned some things
uh about like how things uh work there
dude that is the quote that is the quote
that i want to take away from this
podcast if you've been working in a
career for five years you should have
learned some things
like that's it that you should have
learned some things and yet that's right
people that have been in a career for
five years and it just like
a slightly less [ __ ] version of the
person that they were when they joined
right um and i think it's yeah it's like
like in any theater like mark like
there's like i don't know five or ten
books maybe that you could like read on
marketing and like that's like probably
70 percent of the stuff you need to know
like it's not
like at least the sort of like
fundamentals uh
are the basics kind of thing so just
like you know i think it's particularly
if you whatever you're doing like if
you're if you're reading about something
and you're doing at the same time
you get that really tight feedback loop
right you're like i'm reading about how
to
to do some mark you know email marketing
or whatever and then i'm like working on
doing email marketing i think oh
actually like well what about this
problem that i just ran into and then
you know you can go back and forth and
that that sort of
loop of um of practicing and reading
is much more productive than sort of
either of those in isolation
um the third one use popular
productivity hacks which everyone on
this podcast will be very
very familiar with what's your current
productivity
setup in terms of the apps that you're
most reliant on
uh i wrote there's an app called focus
mate that i like a lot which is
basically
virtual co-working and so you basically
pick a time uh
whatever 11 a.m and it matches you with
someone somewhere else in the world that
wants to do a 50-minute work session and
it's basically just like a video call
you get on there and they have some like
protocols that they ask people to follow
on the platform but it matches you with
somebody you see like
hi my name's taylor i'm going to be
working on uh you know writing
the first of my newsletter uh in this
session and i find that um
at various times i sort of had like
writing buddies where you know we'd go
meet and we sit in a coffee shop for two
hours or
they'd come to my place so i go to
theirs and that like social pressure is
just like
we it just works for i mean i think it
works for almost everyone but like it
certainly works for me right when i know
that person in like 50 minutes
is going to say like did you do the
newsletter like
no like it's just gonna like i should
just do the newsletter because i don't
want to like tell them i didn't do the
newsletter
um so yeah that that's a big one for me
um right now i do it that's kind of like
a version
i think you mentioned like the pomodoro
technique is for like breaking things
down into chunks right so that's a 50
minute chunk i think typically
pomodoro's like 25 minutes but having
this
like deliberate uh blocks and then i'll
go
whatever go for a walk stretch uh have a
chat with someone
that's cool i like it i like that i like
the idea of that guy um
next up you said use software and
automation how can you use that to be
smart and harder yeah i um
again like this some of this stuff seems
sort of um
obvious but like you know computers are
much more reliable than humans for doing
things you know generally
including yourself right and so you if
you can get a computer to do
uh something for you that will usually
work better so like as a simple example
uh i use a text expander app and what
that is is you type in uh like uh
one of the ones i use is a comma
t-h-a-t and it pulls onto this thing and
says
hi i'd love to set up a time to talk
with you let me know what some times
that are convenient
are you for if you'd like to go ahead
and book a time i have my availability
here right and because i see you know i
do that whatever twice a day every day
forever and then it sends and then
again and it instead of like spending
five emails back and forth trying to
figure out time they work
you know they have all these calendar
apps now i use one called calendly
there's a bunch of them
uh but it just like syncs up with my
google calendar and the person can say
you know
taylor's free at these times and they
book um
you talked about whatever time they want
you talked about upwork
and like tiny hands as well do you do
you outsource much
of the stuff that you do or are you
quite sort of siloed
uh i do yeah there's an app called fancy
hands it's like i think you pay like
five minutes
per 20 to 30 minute tasks kind of thing
um so i do try and use there's just like
a lot of stuff that like they're just i
just can't figure out a good way
to get up like i know you've got to call
the credit card company to discuss it's
like it has to be you right like it has
to be your social security or whatever
like some of these things you can
basically they'll call and they'll wait
on hold for you and they'll get the
operator
and they'll just dial you in as soon as
they have the person and then it's like
a two minute thing right because you're
like hi
you know my name is taylor this is my
social security number
my information whatever like i want to
change this thing and
um so yeah i do i do try to do that
stuff i
um i guess i increasingly i had sort of
like uh
um so i didn't actually find them
through upwork but just a
person that worked me on an ongoing
basis um
that like helps manage a bunch of um but
those kind you know those kinds of
things and also higher level sort of
project management
type stuff dude you know what i tweeted
about this the other day and tons of
people
replied to me and said that they have
the same challenge there needs to be
a how to find
train and work with a pa or va
course for entrepreneurs i don't
there may be some out there if you're
listening and you've got one or you know
one please send it to me because i
desperately need it
but like it's getting to the stage now
where leveraging a personal brand is
starting to hit some scaling limitations
um sure and which is great
because i love being in control of it of
it being me and there's
tons of people out there zoobee my buddy
he's the same like he's
he has like billions of impressions on
twitter
every month and um all of these
different things trying to sell a book
and
uh sometimes i do coaching for people
and i do this that and the other and i'm
just like
it's just him and he replied to my tweet
about i need to
learn how to find train and work with a
pa or va
and he replied to it and he was like i'm
listening desperately like because he
needs it too so
uh someone as anyone just please with
the love of god
make a course on how to work with one
because um
you are right it's it's a challenge with
that stuff there's a website called
gethuman.com which allows you
to use a service that will wait on the
phone until an operator
picks up for you um um
i don't know if that's available in
america but it works in the uk
and i found out about that on the the
life hacks first episode of second
season that we released the other week
so that came out final one fifth the
fifth way to
work smarter not harder develop courage
what does that mean you mentioned it as
one of your
core values yeah and this is i think
like
uh like many people uh i love a good
life hack
right you know you know it's like uh
here's this thing and it's you know
uh your example of like the on it
supplement our life hacks are kind of
like the supplements of
of productivity or something right it's
like i just like do this one quick thing
and like everything's like typing right
like my typing speed i'm going to get it
up by like 20
and then like everything's going to be
like way faster and
uh did and you know i was yeah i had
done that many times and still do that
and um
i i seem to love that i mentioned from
the soul in the game had a tweet called
use courage and wisdom
not labor uh to make money
um i thought that just like so
succinctly captured kind of the idea of
um
productivity for me that usually it's
like i'll just like work harder at it or
i'll come up with like some
trick right like i'll find some like
hack that'll
that'll make this um better but
inevitably for me at least like usually
it's some sort of act of courage that
like ends up being
more productive right it's like this
this hard conversation with my business
partner that i've been avoiding having
that is causing me
to do all this extra work and then i'm
angry about it and i start getting
resentful whatever like if i will just
sit down and like have that
uncomfortable conversation for
15 minutes doesn't take any time at all
uh you know
everything will uh will go better the
other example i think of like you know
when you're in high school and you know
the
pretty girl or the pretty guy or uh
whatever like you know you
obsess it out they're like oh they're
like they'll never like me and they're
like so cool and whatever and this
you know you spend all this time like
you're about to worry about it
and like you could just like figure out
real quick right like you just walk up
and you say like hi
i think you're cool like do you want to
go to the movies or whatever and like
they say yes or they say no i'm like
that's the end of it and then like you
go on with the rest of your life but
uh you know like i like everyone in high
school i suppose but like
i did it too right it's like there's
some girl i was like oh she's so cool
and she's smart and
funny and did it and i'm just gonna
think about this for four years or
whatever and i was like
could have sorted it out in two minutes
it was a two minute job like it could
have been in and out you know there was
no
there was no reason to drop out that way
but it was it was a courage thing i was
like oh god like what is she gonna say
um when i go talk to her is she gonna
like say that i'm dumb or you know like
whatever the thing is
that could be an operating principle in
fact i think it might be one of yours
that you've taken from david allen where
you say
uh just always look for the next action
like what is the way that i can act on
this thing immediately
um and another way to look at that man
i've been thinking about that sort of
situation a lot that there's an
opportunity cost
to ruminating about anything such an
opportunity cost with tons of stuff so i
got this thing
uh this modern wisdom academy which i'm
super excited about launching which is
just going to be a partner for the
podcast so
every day that a podcast episode goes
live which is three days a week at the
moment
um you get a curated summary of all the
key learnings from that episode
on a partner blog and delivered in your
email inbox so you're never gonna forget
anything again it's like
we could even down the line look at
trying to build space repetition into it
so you know you listen to this podcast
and in three months you can't quite
remember all the stuff you said do you
have to go and listen to it again no you
don't you do this
and i've been thinking about it for ages
and i was like you know what it is
i've been thinking about this for so
long it would be simpler and quicker to
just launch the [ __ ] business
so that i don't have to think about it
anymore totally
and that's the same as the girl right
it's like if you're gonna think about
that girl and maybe not go out with any
other girls
who would be even better or cooler or
you find out that actually she's got
like bad breath or she's really a bit of
a [ __ ]
you don't know you don't know if this
business is gonna be a [ __ ] like or
whatever it might be so yeah the
opportunity cost developing the courage
looking for the next actions i am i love
them man
look final thing before you go dude have
you got any book recommendations we get
inundated with recommendations for books
as someone who's
pretty well read is there any that you
think people might not
have might not know about so an example
from me would be
john boyd's biography which i thought
was phenomenal
um but anything else that you think if
you're looking for something a little
bit new that you maybe you haven't heard
of before here's here's a couple of
examples
yeah i think uh i think the fighter
pilot who changed out of war by robert
korum as the john boyle biography which
is awesome i usually i very rarely
i kind of just like chug along with
books usually like i'll start and i'll
pick it up and put it down and that one
i
it was like three days like i just
picked it up and just like crushed the
thing it's like this is so good
um yeah i mentioned the war of art uh
by steven pressfield that's you know i
don't know how well-known that is but i
like that one a lot and then um i guess
my sort of off the wall or
our uh underrated um book that i've
probably
i don't know read four or five times now
is um finite and infinite games by james
p
carse uh he yeah i think that would be a
new one but he is a professor
at uh here he was and he may have passed
away now but he was a
plus philosophy professor at new york
university i think in like the 70s and
80s
and um wrote this book called finite
infinite games and
and the premise is you know there there
are two types of games in life
uh finite games and infinite games
and uh finite games are played according
to known rules
towards a specified end and infinite
games are played by reinventing the
rules
with the purpose of extending play and
uh he
that's that's basically the summary of
the the whole kind of books like for
example like
uh when a uh father is playing catch
with his son
it is not a finite he's not trying to
win catch right he's not trying to
there's not there's no there's rules to
catch and i'm trying to throw at the
hardest and win catch right
you want to make catch fall you're
trying to invent new rules to catch
so you can keep playing catch uh with
your son or
that's my american baseball analogy but
you know you can use the the
football analogy or whatever you want
right it's an infinite game right
the success is like we just get to keep
playing catch uh
into the future and i think that you
know that's true of so many different
areas of life right you can approach
like well once i get to this
thing then i will have won the finite
game whether that's you know the sport
or the the whatever it is
um but you know there's hey you know
there's this whole other way of looking
at which is like you know how could i
how could i
reinvent the rules of this game in a way
that just made it interesting and able
to be able to you know to continue
um extending play so i come back to that
book and just that
really you you really like to read the
first chapter like the rest of the book
is good but like the first 30 pages you
get the whole
he lazy i mean he lays out the whole
idea maybe even only the first 15 or 20
but the first chapter of that book is is
phenomenal that's awesome it's a much
cooler less cliche version of um
like the path is the destination it's
about progress
not perfection and stuff like that i
actually prefer that i prefer talking
about the way that the game gets played
and being able to continue playing the
game as well
i think that's a that's a cooler way to
do it
man we made it we did it great success
we made it through um everything that
we've gone through the
your phenomenal blog which like you say
300
300 posts from the last god knows how
long um
what's next or is there any other stuff
that you want to plug any stuff that
people should go and have a look at
uh no yeah check out the blog i have a
newsletter
uh i write random things on there so if
you're into that stuff
you know go for it that's awesome man
thank you
so much for your time taylor i've really
really enjoyed this
cheers pleasure
you